as we head into a new workweek the
24-day partial government shutdown drags
on it is now the longest in US history a
new CBS News poll shows seven in ten
Americans are worried about the impact
on the economy and economists say it can
cost one to two billion dollars have
lost output a week nearly half in that
poll blame the president for the
shutdown while 30 percent blame
Democrats in Congress Paula Reid is at
the White House Paula good morning good
morning John the president still tells
his advisors that he wants a deal before
he will reopen the government but so far
he has rejected every proposal that has
been brought to him including those from
his own party on Sunday GOP Senator
Lindsey Graham said that he urged the
president opened the government for
three weeks and then declare a national
emergency if no compromise could be
reached but the president refused and
over the weekend Republicans expressed
outrage as roughly 30 Democratic
lawmakers traveled to Puerto Rico to see
the musical Hamilton and tour hurricane
recovery efforts this widely shared
photo though shows senator Menendez at
the beach House Speaker Nancy Pelosi and
Senate Minority Leader Chuck Schumer did
not make the trip and they insist that a
deal is still possible if the president
gives way on funding for a wall
meanwhile some government workers have
officially missed their first paychecks
TSA says it is seeing a sharp increase
in the number of absences compared to
this time last year but they insist
security standards have not been
compromised but the president tells
advisors he still thinks they can win
the shutdown because it keeps attention
on the border and distracts from other
controversies currently swirling around
the White House John speaking of one of
those swirling stories Paula the
Washington Post reported that President
Trump has taken extraordinary measures
to conceal the details of his
conversations with Russian President
Vladimir Putin so how is Washington
responding to that well today
congressional lawyers will meet to
decide whether or not they should
subpoena an interpreter who was there
during a meeting between President
Vladimir Putin and president prompt The
Washington Post is reporting that
following a meeting between the two
leaders President Trump took notes from
the interpreter and can see
details of what was discussed even from
members of his own administration now
it's a one-two punch then the New York
Times also reported but after the
president fired James Comey in May of
2017
law enforcement officials became so
concerned with the president's behavior
that the FBI opened a
counterintelligence investigation into
the president's relationship with Russia
truly extraordinary
now Special Counsel Robert Muller
eventually took over that investigation
several days after it was opened this
weekend the president was asked during a
pretty friendly Fox News interview if he
was indeed an agent of Russia he called
the question insulting and did not even
answer it directly now we are still
waiting for the special counsels final
report but a lot of Republicans are
worried now that this will be much more
damaging than they previously
appreciated John all right Paula thank
you